[Music]  [Music]  he's under a huge amount of pressure  facing a large and complex extradition  case in circumstances where we don't  have sufficient access to him his  lawyers are not able to hand him papers  in the prison it takes weeks for papers  to reach him he doesn't have a laptop to  be able to prepare this material on it's  a very difficult situation in which to  be defending such a serious extradition  case this case raises such fundamental  questions about freedom of speech we  heard in court today it's an outrageous  affront to journalistic protections and  on that basis we would certainly hope  that no journalist or publisher would be  extradited many circumstances but of  course it's a very long way ahead and  we'll have to wait to see what happens  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]